الشمس في قطاع غزه وفي القدس وايضا في
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه اقتربت
الشمس من الاشراق اتمنى ان يعود الهدوء
الى تلك المنطقه زميل زياد يقول ان الهدوء
عاد بالفعل واتمنى قبل اكتمال شروق الشمس
يعود الهدوء بشكل كامل
على التطورات على الجبهتين على قطاع غزه
وعلى جنوب لبنان ايضا شكرا لك محمد
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام لازلنا معكم في
متابعتي تطورات التصعيد الاسرائيلي في كل
من غزه ولبنان قبل قليل تم اطلاقه رشقه
صاروخيه من قطاع غزه باتجاه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه الحدوديه وكان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انه هاجم اهدافا تابعه
لحركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس في لبنان
بعد ان كثف ضرباته على قطاع غزه وذلك في
اعقابها جمال صاروخيه انطلقت من لبنان على
اسرائيل الخميس وذكر الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بيان الله انه لا يسمح لحماس بالعمل من
داخل لبنان محملا الدوله اللبنانيه
مسؤوليه كل نيران مواجهه تنطلق من اراضيها
دخل نطال عن صفر الراشدين
[موسيقى]
ونبدا المتابعه من غزه معنا من هناك محمد
عوض الصحفيه من غزه محمد اهلا بك هل هناك
اي صواريخ جديده تم اطلاقها من غزه باتجاه
مستوطنات الغلاف
قبل الاجابه على هذا السؤال صهيب بودي
الاشاره هنا لان
مدفعيه الجيش الاسرائيلي بدات تقصف اهدافا
شرق رفح في هذه اللحظات حيث استهدفت
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على شرق
رفح اقصى جنوب قطاع غزه قصفت مواقع تتبع
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ودمرتها بشكل كامل هذه
المواقع هي عباره عن مراتب توجد على
الشريط الحدودي مع مصر والاراضي
الاسرائيليه كذلك
رفح جنوب قطاع غزه جاء ذلك بعد ايضا اطلاق
عدد من المقدسات الصاروخيه من قطاع غزه
اتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه المتحده لقطاع
غزه حيث دوت فقرات الانذار في بلده الى
شمال من
انقطاع غزه
جاءت سافرت الانذار تفعيل جهه تص
بعد اطلاق الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى عدد من
الصواريخ اتجاه هذه البلده الان يعني
الهدوء عاد تدريجيا لكن
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لمواقع رصد الفصائل
في رفح جنوب القطاع غزه
الهدوء الذي كنا نركبه منذ نصف ساعه
تقريبا لكن ربما تستمع في الخلفيه اصوات
حديد الطائرات التي ما زالت تحلق
بارتفاعات متفاوته ومنخفضه في كافه اجواء
قطاع غزه انت تعلم منذ بدء التصعيد امس
على
غزه وحتى هذه اللحظه مازال التصعيد
محمد
محمد صوتك تقطع ولكن نعم اشكرك اذا على كل
هذه المعلومات الجديده اذا المدفعيه
اسرائيليه تستهدف شرق رفح كما افادنا محمد
عوض قصفت مواقع للفصائل الفلسطينيه في رفح
كذلك صفارات الانذار دوت في المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه على غلاف قطاع غزه بعد اطلاق
مجموعه من الصواريخ اطلقتها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه من داخل قطاع غزه في حين ذكر
ضيفي بان هناك هدير للطائرات الاسرائيليه
ما يزال يسمع حتى الان في نظرا لاستمرار
الطائرات الاسرائيليه في التحليق على علو
منخفض في سماء غزه معنا الان في هذه
التغطيه الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
عصمت منصور استاذ عصمت اهلا بك معنا اذا
الشمس اشرقت كما نتابع في هذه الصور
المباشره اذا في قطاع غزه يعني هل تعتقد
ان مع بدايه هذا اليوم يمكن القول ان هذه
الجوله من التصعيد قد انتهت
يعني ليس تماما ولكن يمكن القول ان افاق
احتوائها ربما بدات تتضح اكثر مع اشراقه
هذا الصباح كما كنتم الان في النهار تصبح
امكانيه الحركه ونقل الرسائل والتواصل بين
الوسطاء ربما اكبر وانشط ولذلك يعني معالم
وافاق التصعيد بدات تتضح الواضح اننا يعني
لسنا ذاهبون الى مواجهه مفتوحه وشامله حتى
الان هذه المؤشرات التي نلمسها
يدفعك الى هذا الاعتقاد استاذ عصمت لانه
بالليله الماضيه طوال ساعات التغطيه
الساده الهدوء في قطاع غزه اعتقدنا ان
الامر قد انتهى ثم عاد وتفجر لكن في جنوب
لبنان ما الذي يدفعك للاعتقاد بان هذه
الجوله يعني لن تستمر اكثر من هذا
انا كل نهار وتستمر ولكن لن تتوسع نطاقها
وتتعمق ويصل القصف الى السنابر السبع وتل
ابيب وتقصف ادراج في غزه وغيرها هذا يعني
حتى الان يبدو انه ليس هو الوجهه الذي
يجعلنا نعتقد ذلك هو عوامل كثيره عوامل
اسرائيليه داخليه عوامل لها علاقه
بالائتلاف او ابنه علاقه لا علاقه
بالتوقيت شهر رمضان اعياد
اليهوديه اعوام لها علاقه بايضا عن
الاهداف الاسرائيليه ماذا يمكن ان تحقق
ماذا وضعت اهداف اسرائيل من ذلك وهل
تستطيع تحقيقها فعلا توحيد الجبهات
والساحات هذا اي تصعيد الان سيوحد هذه
يكرس معادلات كثيره الحاله في الضفه
والغليان الذي تشهدوا وايضا ما قيل عن ضغط
امريكي على اسرائيل يعني لا يوجد ضوء اخضر
امريكي كما يبدو لمواجهه مفتوحه كان واضحا
ان سترد وهذا لا يمكن يعني حتى عندما توجه
الوسطاء في البدايه سنرد
وهذا يعني يمكن اعتباره شيء مفهوم في
التقاليد وطريقه التعامل دوله الاحتلال
ولكن حجم هذا الرد حتى الان يظهر يعني نحن
نتحدث عن قصف محدود جدا ودقيق ليس شامل
ولا واسع وايضا رد من المقاومه في مناطق
لا زالت ضمن النطاق غلاف غزه لم تتجاوز
غلاف غزه كل هذه المؤشرات لكن هل هذا يعني
انه الامور انتهت انا اعتقد انه يعني ربما
يحتاج بعض الوقت يحتاج ايضا الى بعض الوقت
والوصايه يحتاجون الى بعض الوقت نامل انه
خلال هذا الوقت الا يحدث حدث وتطور
يحرث الامور بشكل كبير بمعنى ان انت يقع
صاروخ او كثيفه اسرائيليه او من المقاومه
توقع عدد كبير من الشهداء او الكتله
الاسرائيلي عندها يمكن ان يصبح ضبط الامور
اصعب على الجبهه اللبنانيه يعني
حزب الله قادر على ضبط نفسه هو لا لو اراد
التدخل من البدايه هو قصف لكن واضح انه لا
يريد التدخل لم يرد على قصف الليله كما
يبدو وبالتالي هذا يعني يجعل هذه الجبهه
وكانها يعني استوفت ردها هذا ما يظهر حتى
الان الغريب انه الكائنات لم يعلن شيء لم
يعلن عن نتائج ولا وضع اسم للعمليه ولا
وضع اهداف لها تحدث فقط عن انه تبنى توسيط
لاجهزه الامنيه ما هي هذه التوصيات ما هي
طبيعتها هذا الغموض وهذا يعني هذه اللغه
المنضبطه دعنا نكون بالعاده اسرائيل خلال
ساعات تطلق اسم على العمليه وتحدد لها
اهداف وتبدا بعمليه حشد لقواتها
واستنفار وربما استدعاء احتياط كل
واجراءات خاصه وفتح ملاجئ في مزققات واسعه
كل هذا لم يحدث حتى الان هل هذه خدعه لا
احد يعلم ولكن ظاهريا يبدو الامور بهذا
الاتجاه
دعنا نرصد الوضع من على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه معنى من هناك مدير
مكتب بالعربيه زياد حلبي زياد بدايه اخر
المستجدات عندك
الهدوء هو سيد الموقف منذ الغارات
الاسرائيليه المحدوده التي شنت اطلاق سته
صواريخ من المقاتلات على موقعين جنوب
مدينه سور قالت اسرائيل ان انهما تابعان
لحركه حماس عمليا
لا يجري الكثير على هذه الجبهه وبالتالي
يمكن القول بان هذا الامر قد يكون انتهى
طالما ان حزب الله لم يرد برشق صاروخيه
لكن طبعا التاهب ما يزال قائما لهذا السبب
للخشيه الاسرائيليه من ان يحدث ذلك في
الساعات المقبله
زياد قالت ان لبنان واسرائيل لا تريدان
الحرب بعد هذا التصعيد
ما المزيد مما جاء في بيان اليونيفال
للقوه الدوليه
هي قالت انها رصدت الغارات الاسرائيليه
جنوب مدينه سور وانها اسرائيل ابلغتها
مسبقا بانها سترد طبعا لن تبلغها في لحظه
القصف ولكن ابلغتها بشكل عام مررت رساله
لليونيفل وهذا يعني بانها مررت رساله
للبنان ولحزب الله بانها ستقصف بشكل محدود
في لبنان هذا ما قاله بيان اليونيفل بانه
اطلع على اسرائيل بانها تريد ان ترد على
صواريخ التي استهدفتها مع هذا التقدير
الذي فيه شيء من التحليل السياسي
لليونيفيلد بان اسرائيل ولبنان غير معنيين
نعم طيب زياد بعد كل هذا الوقت الان
الهدوء سيد الموقف الان
ما الذي تكشف عن طبيعه المواقع التي
استهدفتها اسرائيل التي قالت انها استهدفت
مواقع لحماس في جنوب لبنان
ما طبيعه هذه المواقع المستهدفه حتى الان
في جنوب لبنان وحجم الخسائر
يعني لا يجوز الحديث حتى عن مواقع بالمعنى
التقليدي لا يوجد مواقع حقيقيه
للفصائل الفلسطينيه في جنوب لبنان الكل
يعرف ذلك اسرائيل قصفت مكتبا تابعا لحركه
حماس لم يكن ربما ماهولا وقصفت مبنى اخر
في موقع اخر وفي مناطق زراعيه مفتوحه ايضا
بهذا المعنى قلنا منذ البدايه بانه بناء
على القرار الاسرائيلي هي لا تريد ان
تستهدف اهدافا تابعه لحزب الله ولا بنى
تحتيه تابعه للدوله اللبنانيه بهذا المعنى
لم تكن لديها اهداف حقيقيه اصلا خلا هذا
المبنى الذي قصف كما قلت تقول انه يتبع
الحماس شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان اذا مراسل
العربيه ومدير مكتب العربيه
زياد حلبي كنت معنا من الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه ونذهب الى مراسلنا عبد الحفيظ
جعوان
عبد الحفيظ اهلا بك اخر المعطيات لديك في
هذه الساعه
انا اراقب المشهد حاليا في المسجد الاقصى
هناك توتر كبير عقب التظاهره خرجت الاف
المصلين بعد صلاه الفجر في ساحات المسجد
الاقصى تضامنا مما يجري فيه قطاعه غزه
والان هناك توتر كبير الشرطه الاسرائيليه
تتواجد على مداخل المسجد على الابواب
وهناك عدد كبير من المصلين الذين يتواجدون
داخل المسجد الاقصى واحتمال المواجهه وارد
في كل لحظه وكل دقيقه
هذا المكان الذي شهد مواجهات خلال الايام
الماضيه والتي اشعلت المواجهه برومتها على
مختلف الجبهات في قطاع غزه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عوده ونشر بيانا محدثا قال انه
قصف مزيدا من الاهداف التي تتبع لحركه في
حماس منها
في في رفح وايضا
اماكن اخرى للتدريب واماكن لتصنيع الاسلحه
وفق بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي تطبع ايضا
لحركه حماس فيما استمرها اطلاق الصواريخ
من قطاع غزه اخرها كان قبل نحو نصف ساعه
عندما
اصاب صاروخ بشكل مباشر مبنى في بلده
السبيروت الاسرائيليه القريبه من حدود
قطاع غزه
وادى هذا الصاروخ الى اضرار ماديه ولكن لا
يوجد اصابات وفقه
الطواقف الطبيه الاسرائيليه ايضا نصيحه
الفلسطينيه اصدرت بيانا دامت فيه
يعني الهجوم الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف
مستشفى الاطفال مستشفى الدره للاطفال في
منطقه حي التفاحه الشرقي قطاعي غزه يبدو
ان قطعه من صاروخ من القبه الحديديه سقط
على
وتسبب بحاله من الهلع والخوف الشديد سواء
للطاقم الطبي او للاطفال الموجودين داخل
المستشفى غير ذلك لا يوجد اي اصابات يعني
سجلتها وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه باستثناء
يعني فتره اصيب نتيجه للتهشم زجاج منزله
نظرا
لكثافه الغارات وقوتها والتحديدا بمنطقه
خان يونس نعم طيب عبد الحفيظ عقب التوتر
الذي تحدثت عنه عقب صلاه الفجر ما بين
الفلسطينيين
والقوات الاسرائيليه في محيط المسجد
الاقصى ماذا ننتظر كذلك اليوم بحكم صلاه
الجمعه ايضا وبحكم هذا التوتر القائم في
المسجد الاقصى كذلك
يعني هو اختبار كبير
للقوات الامن الاسرائيليه كيف ستتعامل مع
الجموع الجمعه الماضيه صهيب وصل نحو
200,000 فلسطيني الى المسجد الاقصى وكان
هناك كثافه غير مسبوقه لعدد المصلين ومن
المتوقع ايضا في هذه الجمعه ان تصل هذه
الاعداد اسرائيل كانت قد اعلنت اغلاقا
شاملا على الضفه الغربيه بسبب الاعياد
اليهوديه ولكن لها استثنت هذا اليوم وقالت
انها ستسمح للرجال من هم فوق سن الاربعين
عاما بالتوجه من الضفه الغربيه الى القدس
على الاضافه ايضا الى الاف المصلين الذين
قد يفدوا من مدن الداخل الى المسجد الاقصى
وكان هناك دعوات طوال الاسبوع لحشد
المصلين والتوجه الى المسجد الاقصى الان
هناك التوتر وسنرى ان سيحدث مواجهه بين
المصلين فجرا والشرطه الاسرائيليه وان كان
ذلك
صلاه الجمعه على
زوايا الصوره نشاهد غزه الان ونشاهد فيها
البدر المكتمل الان طبعا بعد يعني دخولنا
في يوم الجمعه بعد ساعات يعني كانت
السماء اضاءت صواريخ بالغارات الاسرائيليه
طبعا الان الهدوء الحذر يبقى سيد الموقف
كما نتابع معكم في هذه الصور المباشره في
غزه الان طبعا جنوب لبنان كذلك نال نصيبه
بعد ساعات قليله من قصف غزه
في موقعين في مخيم الرشيديه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين في صور جنوبي لبنان طيب عبد
الحفيظ اذا التوتر ما يزال سيد الموقف في
المسجد الاقصى والهدوء الحذر كذلك دعني
اسالك عن موقف الفصائل الفلسطينيه كذلك
وردها مع استمرار اطلاق الصواريخ على مست
وطنات الغلاف غلاف قطاع غزه خاصه
هل هناك اي بيانات اي مواقف تنبئ عما
ستفعله الفصائل اذا كانت ستستمر في القصف
ام لا
مجمل الفصائل الفلسطينيه صهيبه اصدرت
البيانات سواء يعني حتى الاجنحه المسلحه
تحديدا لحركه حماس او الجهاد وغيرها اصدرت
ايضا بيانات منفصله وقالت انها سوف ترد
على الهجوم الاسرائيلي وقالت انها اي يعني
ارتداء اسرائيلي من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
على المصلين في المسجد الاقصى سوف يرد
عليه باطلاق الصواريخ وبعمليات كان هناك
دعوات لتنفيذ عمليات عسكريه في الضفه
الغربيه ضد اهداف الاسرائيليه ونحن ايضا
صهيب مشهد يعني
زياده في عدد هذه العمليات وتحديدا عمليات
اطلاق نار التي تستهدف مواقع اسرائيليه
ومعسكرات اسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه خلال
الثلاث ايام الماضيه بالتزامن مع قمع
المعتكبين في المسجد الاقصى شهدنا الشريط
عمليات اطلاق النار لعلها اخرها كان هذه
الليله عند حجز جبع ش عندما اطلق مسلح
عمار على مجموعه من الجنود واصابه جلديا
بجروح اضافه لعمليات اطلاق نار اخرى
مختلفه في الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي كل
الاعين عاده تعود الى
القدس الى المسجد الاقصى الذي يعني هو
مربط الفرس في كل ما يجري وان كانت الامور
ستتم على ما يرام في هذه الجمعه اما اننا
سنشهد مواجهات وتوترات وبالتالي يمكن ان
يعني ان تشتغل الجبهات مره اخرى نعم طيب
فيما يتعلق بغزه كنا سمعنا اخبارنا عن
الوساطه المصريه وكذلك
الامريكيه كذلك فيما يتعلق بجنوب لبنان
كان هناك بيان لليونيفل اكد ان لبنان
واسرائيل لا يريدان الحرب
دعني اسالك عن الوساطه المصريه ما الذي
رشح كذلك عن هذه الاتصالات
والى اي حد جهود احتواء التصعيد او هذه
الجوله من التصعيد هي قويه
الوساطه المصريه يعني جديده وقديمه الملف
غزه يعني عاده ما يكون في كنف الجانب
المصري الذي يحاول عاده الضغط سواء على
الفصائل الفلسطينيه او على اسرائيل لمنع
التصعيد نظرا لان اي
حدث يعني اي اي تصعيد يجري في غزه عاده مع
مصر تكون مسؤوله بشكل مباشر حتى ان ملف
اعاده الاعمار الصهيب الذي يعني مازال يتم
حتى هذه حتى هذه الايام منذ عامين او
ثلاثه اعوام الابراج التي نسفت مصر هي
المسؤوله بشكل مباشر عن اعاده اعمار هذه
المباني التي هدمت واعاده بناء الطرق التي
تم نسبها بسبب الصواريخ الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي مصر معنيه بشكل كبير ان تنجح
جهودها سواء جهودها
الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه او السياسيه في في
غزه هناك يعني الهدوء مقابل الهدوء لا
يوجد اكثر من نعم هذه اللحظه وكانت
اسرائيل قد وعدت الجانب المصري كما فهمنا
بانه ان توقفت الفصائل الفلسطينيه اطلاق
الصواريخ فهي ستوقف جاراتها وهذا مرجح
بشكل كبير لان التصعيد كان
محدودا هذه الليله وان كان كثيفا جدا
ولكنه يسمى التصعيد المضبوط بمعنى يعني
هناك قواعد اشتباك محدده اصبحنا نشاهدها
خلال العوامل الماضيه ونفهم من خلالها ان
هذا التصعيد يكون محدودا وينتهي في بطون
ساعات ولن يستمر ولن يطول اكثر من ذلك نعم
طيب ونعود الان الى محمد عوض من غزه محمد
كنت قبل قليل حدثتنا عن القصف الجديد على
شرق رفح الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان سلاح
الجو استهدف موقعا
لانتاج الاسلحه ونفقا في قطاع غزه
ايضا
ما التفاصيل المتوافره كذلك عن هذا القصف
على رفح محمد
نعم يا صهيب تتواصل
الغارات الايطاليه على مواقع تدفع للفصائل
الفلسطينيه رغم اننا كنا نتحدث عن هدوء في
تمام الساعه الثالثه صباحا لكن سرعان ما
تغيرت سوره الوضع في غزه راس في خان يونس
وشرق غزه وشمالها ايضا حتى قبل حوالي 40
دقيقه رفضنا قصف
لنقطه الرصد تتبع للفصائل الفلسطينيه في
رفح جنوبك قطاع غزه وهذه
محمد
طيب مره اخرى فقدنا صوت محمد عوض اذا من
غزه نعود اليه بعد قليل
نعم ومعنى الان
اذا ايضا ايضا من غزه عصمت منصور الخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه استاذ عصمت اعود
اليك مره اخرى ما دلاله يعني هناك من يعلق
على يعني
المواقع التي استهدفتها اسرائيل في جنوب
لبنان خاصه بانها ليست بتلك الاهميه يعني
ما دلاله ذلك
هذا له دلاله كبيره
الاهداف التي تختارها اسرائيل ونحن نعلم
ان اسرائيل لديها بنك اهداف بنك اهداف
ربما هائل في لبنان وفي غزه هي تعمل على
تجميع هذه الاهداف استخباراتيا ومن خلال
التصوير بطائرات استطلاع او حتى اكبر
صناعيه او غيرها من الوسائل الاستخباراتيه
تجميع اهداف على مدى سنوات واشهر وعندما
تاتي الفرصه
ومواجهه تبدا باستهداف هذه الاهداف بنوك
الاهداف كما تطلق عليها لذلك انا واثق وكل
احد يستطيع ان يستنتج ان اسرائيل لديها
اهداف يمكن ان تستهدفها ولكن ان تختار ان
تقصف اهداف يعني ليست حيويه ولا
تخل بالتوازن هذا يعني انه رساله انها
تريد ان ترد تريد ان تحفظ ماء وجهها
ولكنها لا تريد التصعيد
وهذا لا تريد التصعيد هل من يعني من واقع
تفاهمات توازنات المرحله ام يعني من واقع
ضعف ربما بسبب الازمه الداخليه
هذا واحد من نعم هو بالواقع عده عوامل
ربما في مقدمتها لازم الداخليه الان ربما
لا يقتنع الكثير من الاسرائيليين انه
نتنياهو يذهب الى مواجهه وخاصه اذا انتهت
هذا الوجه دون اي نتائج تذكر انه لا يذهب
من اجل التغطيه على
الازمه الداخليه وحرف الانظار عنها وكل ما
يعني يريد ان يبرروا من اصلاحات هذا هذا
امر مهم عندما لا يكون له جمهور داعم وعمق
صلب وجبهه داخليه متماسكه هذا عامل مهم
جدا ايضا هناك امور لها علاقه بطبيعه
الساحه اللبنانيه
وتعقيدات دخول حزب الله على المواجهه حزب
الله دخوله سيعني يعني يعني مدى وشكل
وكثافه نيران مختلفه كليا وايضا اسرائيليا
وهذا يعني لا يمكن السيطره عليه بسهوله
وبالتالي هذا ايضا عامل يشكل نوع من الردع
المتبادل ايضا ربما ط القصف الذي وجه من
لبنان هو الاخر لم يكن لم يستهدف اماكن
حساسه ولا يستخدم صواريخ بعيده المدى او
دقيقه والى اخره صواريخ كتيوشا وهذه مداها
ليس بعيد وايضا دقتها ليست كبيره ولم توقع
يعني قتلى ولا اصابات كبيره
وبالتالي هذا امر يمكن احتوائه نعم
الخطوات تبدو مدروسه من جميع الاطراف
واعود مره اخرى على التشديد الاسرائيلي
يعني في الاعلان كان لافت انه قالوا انه
اسرائيل استهدفت مواقع لحماس في جنوب
لبنان
الغايه من ذلك انه يبدو انه لا تريد ان
تدخل في مواجهه مع حزب الله او لا تريد ان
يكون موضوع احتواء هذه الجوله يعني
يحفظ ماء وجه الجميع على ما يبدو هكذا
يعني احد
المحاليين الاسرائيليين وصف المواجهه
بانها على اكثر من جبهه ولكن مع تنظيم
واحد يعني هي في القدس وهم يعتقدون انه
حماس هو من يحرض
ويهيج من اجل التصعيد القدساتهم
وفي لبنان وفي غزه وانه حماس يلتفت وراء
كل هذه الجبهات وبالتالي حماس ومن اللحظه
الاولى في اول بيان للجيش الاحتلال هو
اشار باصبع الاتهام بشكل مباشر وبالاسم
لحركه حماس هذا يعني كي لا يترك اي مجال
للبس انه هو مواجهته مع حماس وايضا نفي
حزب الله الذي جاء بعد دقائق من
القصف هو الاخر له دلالا وحزب الله نحن
نعلم انه هناك يعني جنوب من يسيطر على
الجنوب من يعتبر نفوذ منطقه نفوذ له في
الجنوب هو حزب الله وانه اي شيء يتم اما
بغض النظر يعني يغض النظر عنه حزب الله او
يكون شريك به او يدفع باتجاهه لكن ان
يتنصل هذا ايضا فيه رساله لاسرائيل
والاطراف الاخرى انه نحن لا نريد الدخول
نواجهه هذا يعني رد من فصيل فلسطيني
وبالتالي دخولنا نحن في المواجهه كان
سيغير كثيرا وكان بامكاننا ان نكون بهذا
الامر لذا يعني واضح انه كل هذه العوامل
كان الهدف منها ايصال رسائل تثبيت معادلات
ايصال رسائل تحديدا بما يتعلق بالاقصى
والمس بالاقصى
والتطاول الذي جرى والتنكيل داخل الاقصى
داخل المسجد وضد المصلين انه هذا الامر لا
يمكن السكوت عليه ولكن ايضا فيه رساله انه
التنسيق بين حماس وحزب الله بلغ مستوى
يعني عالي جدا وانه الجبهات والساحات لم
تعد ضفه غزه او القدس غزه الان ضفه غزه لب
نان وانه يعني حماس تريد ان تكون طبعا
معها حزب الله ومحور المقاومه انه
الاستهداف الاقصى سيكون الرد عليه بمستوى
اعلى من هذا من خلال لبنان وبفتح جبهات
جديده يعني هذه ايضا معادله وهذه تركيبه
وهذا تقارب ووجود مسلح لحماس في لبنان
وبنيه تحتيه ايضا اسرائيل تاخذ بالاعتبار
نعم طيب ينضم الان الينا في هذه التغطيه
كذلك من غزه الصحفي نضال الخضراء نضال
اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه من العربيه
مع طلوع شمس هذا الجمعه على غزه بعد هذه
الليله الساخنه
هل يسود هذا الهدوء هل يسود شعور بان هذه
الجوله قد انتهت ام الغزيون مقبلون ربما
على تصعيد اكبر اليوم
الان
هو اكل
[موسيقى]
في حاله من الاشتباك المستمر مع الاحتلال
يعني لا يوجد
سنه الا ان يكون هناك مواجهه او مواجهه
حين مع هذا الاحتلال فبالتالي سكان قطاع
غزه هم معتادون على هذه الحاله خاصه يعني
في هذا التوقيت نحن في شهر رمضان والمشاهد
التي
ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني على وسائل الاعلام
من اقتحام
للمسجد الاقصى والاعتداء على النساء
بالهروات بهذه الوحشيه من قبل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه كان يعني مشهد يعني
غير عادي وكان يعني مشهد بصراحه يعني
استثنائي وشك الحاله من
الاستفزاز لدى كل ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
بالتالي يعني هناك توقع من من ابناء قطاع
غزه اما ان هذه المواجهه ان هذه المواجهه
يعني تستمر برغم ان كما قلنا ان يعني من
الواضح ان البيانات الوارده من خلال
الاعلام ومن خلال الميدان تؤكد ان
ان القوى المقاومه
واسرائيل لم يتجاوز قواعد الاشتباك لحد
هذه اللحظه وفي سيما في ظل تدخل الوسطاء
الامم المتحده والمصريين مما يعني هذا
يرفع احتمال ان يتم
احتواء الموقف الا اذا يعني تجاوزت
اسرائيل هذه الحدود وقامت يعني بعمليه
بعمليه بعمليه اغتيال الى احد قاده
المقاومه او يعني ضرب معين يستهدف يعني
مدنيين من الممكن ان يدفع الى يعني
توسع المواجهه مع الاحتلال هذا يعني
ننتظره يعني في الساعات القادمه خاصه ان
اليوم الجمعه واليوم الجمعه الثالثه من
رمضان
وهناك يعني تهديدات من المنظمات الصهيونيه
الاقتحام
المسجد الاقصى وذبح القرابين نحن سننتظر
يعني هل ستستطيع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
السيطره
ومنع المستوطنين من الاقتحام
والسماح
للفلسطينيين ان يؤدوا صلاه الجمعه بشكل
طبيعي وبشكل اعتيادي يعني الله حظنا
الساعات القادمه هي يعني ساعات
[موسيقى]
حاسمه في في في في في هذا التصعيد اذا كنا
ذاهبون الى تصعيد او اذا كنا يعني ذاهبون
الى الى تهدئه نعم ارجو ان تبقى معنا
استاذ نضال دعونا نذهب الان الى الجبهه
الاخرى التي اشتعلت كذلك
في ساعات الفجر من هذه الليله كذلك الى
جنوب لبنان محمود شكر مراسل العربيه معنا
من هناك
محمود هل لديك اي مستجدات جديده او اي
تفاصيل اضافيه كشفت عن الموقعين لدينا
استهدفتهما اسرائيل في جنوب لبنان
الاهميه في هذا التوقيت وفي هذه الاثار
الى انهم من الساعه الرابعه فجرا حتى هذه
الساعه لم يسجل لدينا اي طلعات للطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه او اي غارات اخرى ليس
هنا في منطقه الجنوب فحسب انما ايضا على
طول امتداد الاراضي اللبنانيه هذا في
الجزء الاول في الجزء الثاني اتكشف الان
الضوء الاغارات هي استهدفت هذه المنطقه
وجغرافيه هذا المكان في سهل ليلي نحن كنا
في المنطقه التي استهدفها بالضبط
الثانيه ولكن المخابرات العسكريه طلبت منا
منذ حوالي نصف ساعه اخلاء المنطقه التحسبا
لاي اجراءات او لاي غارات لربما بظنهم ان
تعود وطلبوا ان من المواطنين ومن الكل ان
تبقى المنطقه منطقه عسكريه ولذلك القوى
العسكريه من مخابرات للجيش للجيش اللبناني
هم يقومون بعمليات مسح لهذه البساتين
لتحديد الاماناطق الصفر التي استضافتها
الغاره الثانيه الغاره الاولى كانت
على جانب الراشديه من المخيم القاره
الثانيه كانت في هذه البساتين الجانب
الاسرائيلي بحسب البيانات التي اشار اليها
وتحدث عن استهداف بنيه التحتيه البنيه
التحتيه بالمفهوم العسكري هي تكون مراكز
او مكاتب او ايضا اماكن لتجمع
مقاتلين او لمجموعات عسكريه ولكن بطبيعه
اذا انه حتى هذه الساعه لم يسجل لدينا
ايضا عن وقوع بعد يدلل هذا الامر على
اخلاء تام لهذه المراكز او لهذه المكاتب
من حركه حماس او من
المنظمات الفلسطينيه في منطقه
عدا ذلك بدات الامور يعني تظهر للاعيان
هنالك ايضا بيان من
الامم المتحده اشار الى ان اسرائيل ابلغت
الى انها ستقوم بضربه وهذا
حصل بالفعل عندما اشار الى انه بعد دقائق
بدات هذا الغارات ولكن الكل الاطراف يدعو
بحسب البيانات التي خرجت الى الشد الاعصاب
والى ضبط الهدوء والى عدم الانجرار الى
مواجهه واسعه او مفتوحه ولكن بالترديد
تبقى الاشاره الاهم في هذه النقطه الى انه
لربما الى ان هذا الرد اقتصر على غاره
الفجر مع الرابعه بسته صواريخ على غارتين
وحتى هذه الساعه اعود ليؤكد الى انه لم
يسجل لدينا اي امتداد على طول الاراضي
اللبنانيه لاي غاره اخرى او اشتباك على
الحدود او لاي من عسكري طيب محمود
المنطقتين المستهدفتان بهذا القصف
الصاروخي الاسرائيلي
بسته صواريخ بالتحديد كما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي
هل هما ذات المنطقه التي تم اطلاق منها
وابل الصواريخ على اسرائيل
بالامس ونسبته اسرائيل لنشطاء فلسطينيين
من جنوب لبنان
نعم صهيب ساذهب معك للاجابه عن هذا السؤال
بالصوره مع الزميل علي نذهب بالصوره الى
هذه الجهه الصواريخ مع العصر خرجت من هذه
الهضاب التي هي امامنا مباشره هذه البقعه
التي خرجت منها الصواريخ مع الساعه
الثالثه عصرا على امتداد هذا الجبل
نزولا الى الزبقين وايضا الى منطقه
القليليه منطقه القليلين عندما نتحدث
عليها هي هذا الشارع الذي نحن فيه زبعين
هي بالمنطقه الثانيه الاطلاق الصواريخ
الذي حصل والذي تقريبا هو 35 35 صاروخا هو
خرجت من هذه المنطقه اما القصف الاسرائيلي
الذي حصل فالقصف على السيل حتى ايضا اخذ
معك بالصوره بالتدليل حتى نطبق الاحداثيات
على الواقع الارضي هي اخر هذا الشارع على
امتداد سته الى
700 كيلو 700 متر كانت شعاع عمليات
الشظايا التي تشذذ هنا كان السؤال هل ان
الغاره هي وقعت في هذا البستان او ان
الغاره وقعت في البستان الاخر هنا كان
التذليل والبحث ولكن البيت الذي اصيب
هنالك بيت على المقلب الاخر يبعد عنا
حوالي 600 700 متر هو تشظى بشظايا نوعا ما
اكبر من الشظايا التي هي على الطريق وتهدم
جزء من هذا السقف بالاضافه ايضا الى جسر
في تلك المنطقه اما الغاره الاولى هي كانت
عند الراشديه في اخراج بين البلدتين اي
الاقلينيه من هذه الجهه وايضا مخيم
الراشديه من الجهه الثانيه
نعم اذن طيب اسالك كذلك يعني عن المواقف
محمود طبعا نعلم انه ساعات الليل
ربما لا يكون فيها
المجال لمواقف او تصريحات عدا طبعا بيان
اليونيفال الذي قال انه لبنان واسرائيل
لا تريدان الحرب بعد هذا التصعيد
الاخير
هل ربما هذا البيان يريح قليلا اللبنانيين
باننا لسنا مقبلين على جوله تصعيد كبيره
فقط الامور ستتوقف عند هذا الحد
نعم البيان في اهميته هو في الفقره
الاخيره ساذهب اليه بالنص حتى لا اجتهد
يقول وقال الجانبان انهما لا يريدان الحرب
ان الاجراءات التي تمت خلال اليوم هي
خطيره وتنظر بتصعيد خطير ولكن اغلق البيان
بالقول نحث جميع الاطراف على وقف جميع
اعمال التصعيد عبر الخط الازرق الان يعني
هذا كان منذ حوالي ثلاث ساعات وهذا ما حصل
بالفعل بغض النظر عن اهميه البيان وعن
توقيته وعن التذليل الى ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي والجانب اللبناني ابلاغهم معا
انه ما لا يريدان التصعيد ولكن
الوقائع الميدانيه هي التي تدلل على كل
شيء نتحدث الرابعه الان تقريبا الساعه اذا
ذهبنا اليها هي الساعه السابعه ثلاث ساعات
تقريبا لم يسجل لدينا كما اشرت على امتداد
الاراضي اللبنانيه اي غاره او اي عمليات
قصف مدفعي او اي تحليق للطيران او اي تحرك
ايضا للمجموعات من فصائل الفلسطينيه في
الداخل اللبناني مما يدلل ويعني هذا الى
ان الامور هي تجري ضمن ايقاع موزون جدا
بعمليات القصف وعمليات الرد وبمحدوديتها
وبتوقيتها وباهدافها وبرسائلها وبان الكل
يحث على ضبط النفط وهذا الذي جرى فضلا عن
كل هذا بغض النظر عن الاتصالات او المواقف
السياسيه هنالك مساله بغايه الاهميه من
ارتكاز العسكري هي انه لا توجد لدى
اسرائيل بالاصل
بنوك لاهداف لحماس على الاراضي اللبنانيه
بمعنى انا ليس عندها لا مخيمات تدريب لا
مراكز عسكريه لا مراكز لوجستيه بالمعنى
الكبير هي تختصر على مكاتب امنيه او
عسكريه بمنطقه الى منطقه اخرى وهذا الذي
حصل بالفعل عندما استهدفوا في الغاره
الاولى المكتب في الراشديه محمود
شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان نبقى في متابعه
التطورات على الارض معك اذا انت في جنوب
لبنان اذا في القليليه في
جنوب لبنان ايضا اذا المشاهدين مستمرون
معكم في يعني متابعه
الوضع اذا على الجبهتين على جبهه قطاع غزه
وعلى جبهه الجنوب اللبناني في ضوء ليله
التصعيد الجوله من التصعيد بين اسرائيل
وحماس بالاساس بالنظر الى استهداف مواقع
تابعه لحماس حتى في جنوب لبنان كما قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي
اذا لدينا صور
جديده اذا للتو
يعني على ما يبدو بانها اثار لاطلاق
صواريخ
لا يمكن لا يمكننا ليس بوسن التاكد بعد
يعني لا توجد معلومات اضافيه ايضا
لكنها ربما اثار الليله الفائته اذا من
التصعيد اذا في قطاع غزه
اذا بانتظار ان تتوفر المزيد من المعلومات
حول اذا هاته الصوره
اذا هي صوره مباشره اذا من قطاع غزه
اذا مشاهدينا ربما لما خلفته الليله
الماضيه من التصعيد في قطاع غزه
نعود للمتابعه لا لم اذا كان معنا الان
عبد الحفيظ
جعوان من رام الله عبد الحفيظ تسمعني
اكثر من ساعه ونصف تقريبا ولكن كما تنقلون
الان مباشره
وقت اطلاق هذه الصواريخ عبد الحفيظ متى
كان الان الان
في هذه اللحظات نعم في هذه اللحظات والان
صافي
يعني واضح انه ثلاث صواريخ تقريبا اكثر
نعم نعم يمكن ان كنت لها صواريخ ويمكن ان
يكون اكثر من ذلك اسرائيل تتحدث عن اطلاق
نحو 40 صاروخ هذه الليله من قطاع غزه
باتجاه
مستوطنات الغلاف والبلدات الاسرائيليه في
غلاف قطاع غزه طبعا الاربعين صاروخ معظمها
من المدى القصير والمتوسط وكانت تستهدف
ازدرويد تحديدا التي تعرضت للكم الاكبر
لهذه الصواريخ وبعضها بعض هذه الصواريخ لم
يتم اعتراضها وبعضها اصاب بعض المباني في
ازدرويد دون ان يخلف يعني اصابات في
الجانب الاسرائيلي من المتوقع بعد هذه
الضربه الصا المشهد لا اغراض اسرائيليه
على اماكن اخرى في قطاع غزه عاده في مثل
هذه الجولات من التصعيد الضربه الاخيره
تكون مهمه جدا يعني كل طرف يحاول ان يسدد
هو الضربه الاخيره للطرف الاخر
عبد الحفيظ يعني في كل مره نعتقد انه جوله
التصعيد قد انتهت وانه تم احتواء هذه
الجوله يعني يظهر مستجد اخر بالعاده يعني
في في موجات التصعيد بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
اسرائيل بالعاده ترد على هكذا صواريخ يتم
اطلاقها على مستوطنات الغلاف ام لا
نعم اكيد صهيب لانه جزء كبير من هذه
المعركه هو جزء نفسي خاص
بالجمهور سواء الجمهور الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه وبالنسبه لاسرائيل الجمهور الاسرائيلي
وحتى اعضاء الوزراء من اليمين المتطرف
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه والذين يعتبرون
مثل هذه المشاهد هو تراجع وتاكل لقوه
الرضع الاسرائيليه وبالتالي يطالبون بمزيد
من الضربات
على اهداف فلسطينيه وحتى بعمليات اغتيال
لاخراج على الاقل مشهد انتصار او مشهد
راضع كالذي ارادته اسرائيل
محللين هذه الليله عندما كانت طائرات
الاسرائيليه تقصف بالتزامن قطاع غزه
والجنوب اللبناني
اذا مشاهدينا نحن امام التطور جديد اذا في
هذه الساعه اطلاق
رشقه صاروخيه جديده اذا من قطاع غزه
باتجاه مستوطنه
بالقرب من قطاع غزه واعتراض هذه الصواريخ
اذا من منظومه القبه الحديديه
الاسرائيليه كما تابعنا معكم على المباشر
قبل قليل وافدنا بهذه المعلومات مراسلنا
اذا عبد الحفيظ جعوان طيب عبد الحفيظ
اسالك كذلك عن الموقف في القدس والمسجد
الاقصى
كنا تحدثنا قبل قليل انه في ضوء هذه
الليله من التصعيد كان هناك توتر عقب صلاه
الفجر
ما المعلومات المتوفره عن الوضع الان في
المسجد الاقصى
الوضع متوتر للغايه واحتماليه المواجهه
وارده في كل لحظه يعني اسرائيل نشرت عدد
كبير من الشرطه والوحدات الخاصه على
بوابات المسجد
الاقصى وعلى الطرف الاخر هناك المئات من
المصلين الذين انتهوا من صلاه الفجر ولكن
لم يغادروا المسجد ويتجمهرون انهم
يتجمهرون في ساحات المسجد الاقصى قباله
الجنود المباشره
وهناك بعض الهتافات التي تتحدى التواجد
الاسرائيلي في المسجد الاقصى وبالتالي
احتماليه
المواجهه طبقه وارده وان كان هناك البعض
يعني ممن يطالب هؤلاء الشباب بالتروي
قليلا والسماح
للمصلين بفرصه الوصول الى المسجد الاقصى
نظرا لان يعني فرصه الوصول المسجد الاقصى
عاده ما تكون نادره وخصوصا لسكان الضفه
الغربيه التي يعني تقدمها اسرائيل عاده او
تفصيلات في مثل هذه الايام في شهر رمضان
الفضيل وبالتالي فرصه الوصول للمسجد
الاقصى تكون متاحه لفلسطينيين لم يسبق ان
ان وصلوا للمسجد الاقصى طيب عبد الحفيظ
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر اذا حتى الان طبعا
مشاهدينا كما نتابع معكم في هذه التغطيه
التي استمرت معكم طوال ساعات يعني في كل
ساعه نعتقد ان الامور قد هدات
وستهدا ولن تعود مره اخرى الى التصعيد
يبرز تطور جديد نحن في هذه الساعه اذا
امام تفاصيل ومعطى جديد اطلاق 44 صاروخ
اذا حتى الان من قطاع غزه باتجاه
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
كان من بينها اخر ثلاثه صواريخ تمكنا من
مشاهده اثارها اذا ودخانها على الاقل في
ااا في المشهد الذي كنا نتابعه قبل قليل
على المباشر ثلاثه صواريخ على الاقل
توكلنا من رؤيه الدخانها في سماء قطاع غزه
تم اعتراضها من القبه الحديديه
الاسرائيليه كانت متجهه الى مستوطنه
الاسرائيليه معنى الان مره اخرى الاستاذ
عصمت منصور من رام الله الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه استاذ عصمت في يعني
اسرائيل كانت قالت انه طبيعه الرد ومداه
يتوقف كذلك على ما ستفعله الفصائل
الفلسطينيه نحن نشاهد الان رشقه صاروخيه
جديده هل نتوقع
يوما
جديدا ايضا من التصعيد من قبل اسرائيل في
ضوء استمرار اطلاق الصواريخ
يبدو اننا دخلنا في اليوم الثاني للقتال
يعني هذا هذا شيء متوقع انا لا ارى خروج
عن النسق الذي بدات به هذه المواجهه لا
يوجد شيء استثنائي منذ ان بدات حتى الان
في مدى الصواريخ ولا في كثافتها ولا ايضا
في الرد الاسرائيلي وهذا يعني مؤشر يعزز
من الاعتقاد انه ربما الامور تذهب بهذا
الاتجاه لكن بالعاده يعني هذه الوسطات
والجهود التي تبذل لا يتوقف القتال الى ان
تنتهي فقط عندما تحدد ساعه الصفر ويتم
الاتفاق عليها يلتزم الطرفان بها ما دون
ذلك تبقى عمليه القصف
تافه حتى اخر لحظه لذلك ليس هذا هو
المقياس وفك تقديري المقياس هو حجم
الصواريخ ومداها
بطبيعه الرد الاسرائيلي لغه الخطاب كما
تلاحظ يعني حتى الان ليست يعني كسر لكل
القيود
وتلويح وتهديد بشكل يعني حتى وهذا ربما
تعلمه الطرفان انه انت لما بتطلع بتصريحات
عاليه وبتحط اهداف بعيده وعاليه وصعبه
المنال هذا يكب لك ويجعلك من الصعب عليك
ان نزول عن الشجره والوصول الى حل وسط
لذلك يعني لاحظ الحذر في اللغه
يستطيع ان يكون نحن وجهنا اربع غارات
استهدفنا واحد اثنين ثلاثه وايضا المقاومه
السادسه تكون استهدفنا واحد اثنين ثلاثه
وبذلك ربما يعني يخرج الجميع بصوره امام
جمهوره وامراه العام
بانه حقق ما ما يريد واهم ما حققه انه لم
ينجر الى مواجهه مفتوحه والواجهه المفتوحه
لها كلفتها ولا حساباتها لها كل فتره
والبشريه وايضا لها يعني كل فتره بس
سياسيه على حكومه واستقرار حكومه نتنياهو
على بقائه في منصب وخاصه اذا كان هناك
اعداد قتله وكان هناك خسائر وبقاء في
الملاجئ لفترات طويله هذا الغضب وهذا
سيتحول ضده ولذلك
لا يمكن الجزم ابدا يعني بما ستؤول اليه
الامور خاصه يعني بانتظار يعني صلاه
الجمعه اليوم ونحن في شهر رمضان طبعا
شهدنا قبل قليل لعبد الحفيظ يتحدث عن توتر
ما يزال قائما الان في المسجد الاقصى عقب
صلاه الفجر وحتى الان
هل نتوقع ماذا نتوقع بخصوص هذا اليوم
وكذلك التعاطي الاسرائيلي امام الاحتقان
والغضب الموجود في الاقصى
اليوم هو يوم اختبار جدي والاقصى التي
اشعلت كل هذه المواجهه هي كل الانظار الان
ليس فقط انظارنا وانظارنا بالامطار العالم
الدول العالم كلها الان متجهه باتجاه
الاقصى انا افترض انه اسرائيل ستحاول ان
تحتوي قدر الامكان
ان لا يحدث صدامات وان لا يحدث مشاهد
صادمه سواء للمقاومه او للجمهور وربما
تؤدي الى ردود فعل حتى في الضفه نفسها او
في القدس نفسها لذلك يعني من مصلحتها ان
توسع دائره التوتر والتصعيد الامني لانه
هذا يستنزفها فعلا وهذا يعني يخلق عامل
محاكاه اذا هو يعني استعاره الامور في
الاقصى لا احد يضمن انها تنتقل الى رام
الله والى الخليل ولا جنين وغيرها وهناك
اسرائيل نفسها واستخباراتها تحدثت عن حافز
يعني الرئيس الشباك الاسرائيلي قال حافز
غير مسبوق وهكذا وصفه لتنفيذ عمليات
وبالتالي هو يعني
في ظل هذه الاجواء بتصعيد ربما هذا الحافز
يعني يزداد
نعم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على منصور الخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه كنت معنا من رام الله
لا اعلم اذا كان محمد عوض ما يزال معنا
طيب اذا اشكرك محمد عوض كان صوت انقطع
معنا الصحفي من غزه طبعا
والاستاذ نضال الخضره كذلك كان معنا من
قطاع غزه طبعا اضافه الى شبكه مراسلينا
محمود شكر كان معنا من جنوب لبنان وزياد
حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه كان معنا من
الحدود
الاسرائيليه اذا مع لبنان كذلك المشاهدين
هذه هي الساعه انتهت ضمن هذه التغطيه
المستمره لهذه الليله الساخنه من التصعيد
في كل من قطاع غزه وجنوب لبنان شكرا لكم
على كرم المتابعه ابراهيم بدر معكم في
الساعه التاليه الى اللقاء